our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us as
wounded warriors return home from
deployments overseas some are finding
support from a new kind of team chip
Reid
visited the National Veterans wheelchair
games in Louisville to see how sports
like wheelchair rugby are helping them
heal if this looks like combat that's
exactly what these guys want see
intimidation is the fear factor it's the
adrenaline
in this Smash Mouth sport called
wheelchair rugby then it becomes the
Brotherhood a brotherhood born out of
shared service and sacrifice most of us
go through a pretty dark period after
our injuries Noah Courier says for him
the fog didn't lift for seven years that
seven years is sitting at home being
suicidal
but today the Marine is back on a roll
you get your rugby chair and you start
smash it into people you're having a
blast doing it just opens your eyes you
know this has changed your life in a big
way I think everybody that gets in a
rugby chair and now he's changing others
creating the team Oscar Mike military
speak for on the move
here at the National Veterans wheelchair
games put on each year by the group
Paralyzed Veterans of America and the VA
vets take the court in what some call
murder Paul and custom-built chairs that
can cost up to $7,500 even if they don't
always treat them that way it despised
me up more if I get knocked over it just
makes me want to play even more Mike
look it is a teammate of hairier end
Ryan major I have some trash talkers
over here that kind of just get it out
of me he just called you a trash talker
oh no that's that's very mild mild way
major spent six weeks in a coma after
losing both legs to a roadside bomb in
Iraq you know I'm always waiting for
Ryan cuz he's basically just a torso to
come flying out of his hair have you
been knocked out of your chair oh yeah
and you've knocked people out of your
chair sir which is better
oh the knocking people out is is pretty
awesome pretty satisfying yes and that
thrill of the spill has helped major see
that the sky's the limit
after rugby I've done skydiving kayaking
and a scuba diving snorkeling and is
this what gave you the confidence to do
all those things yes sir that confidence
is the key says the tournament's medical
director VA doctor Kenneth Lee when they
go home they feel better they do better
they go out and go get a job now and Lee
knows wheelchair lacrosse helped him
survive post-traumatic stress disorder
after shrapnel from a suicide bomber in
Iraq tore through his head and legs as a
physician when I see these guys getting
really aggressive hitting hard I should
be really worried about it right I'm
actually the opposite I'm like aw he
should have gotten hit him harder and
these vets say sharing those hard knocks
with the next generation gives them a
way to serve so mentoring is a big part
of the biggest thing
service members like to serve most of us
didn't get to choose when we left our
service and we get to continue in for
CBS this morning
chip Reid Louisville Kentucky such a
sacrifice from that group yes and so
true important and wonderful to see them
coming back and coming together the
effect that that game has it just it's
extraordinary and the smile on their
face when they go yeah we're good yeah
we know we're good
very nice chip Reid thank you